scherz à sienne et celle d'acier enfin
enfin après de longues les terribles
semaine l'alsace est passé au vert c'est
un immense soulagement et une source
d'espoir pour les alsaciens après des
semaines d'efforts et de sacrifices
inédit que toutes celles et ceux qui ont
agi pour cela en soit remercié nous
retrouvons une grande partie de notre
liberté
mais cette liberté doit rimer avec
responsabilité
chacun doit continuer à faire son
maximum pour assurer sa sécurité et
celle des autres
nous devons en effet encore et toujours
continuer à porter un masque
dès qu'on sort de chez soi on doit
respecter les distanciation social
éviter des déplacements superflus et les
rassemblements de plus de dix personnes
sept à ce prix et seulement à ce prix
que nous ferons barrage au corps d'un
virus je l'appelais de tous mes voeux à
partir du 2 juin
la règle des 100 km ne s'imposera plus
et les bars les restaurants les cafés
les équipements culturels et
touristiques qui font partie du
patrimoine alsacien vont pouvoir rouvrir
c'est une formidable avancée
ce sont des dizaines de milliers
d'emplois qui sont en jeu c'est aussi
tout simplement la vie qui va pouvoir
progressivement reprendre son cours dans
nos villes et nos villages
nous devront par contre encore patienter
pour voir les frontières avec
l'allemagne et la suisse prouve rires je
le regrette et c'est pourquoi je reste
plus que jamais mobilisée pour accélérer
leur réouverture
une autre bonne nouvelle c'est la
réouverture des collèges
nous y travaillons depuis plusieurs
semaines avec l'éducation nationale pour
accueillir dès la semaine prochaine en
toute sécurité les élèves et les
enseignants
j'en profite pour saluer l'engagement de
toute la communauté éducative
pendant cette période de confinement
elle est en effet restée mobilisée pour
permettre l'accueil des enfants et des
personnels soignants ou assurer la
continuité pédagogique
un grand merci charrs alsacienne charrs
alsacien unie et solidaire
l'alsace fait face à la crise sanitaire
unie et solidaire l'alsace est au rendez
vous de la sortie progressive du
confinement
vous pouvez compter sur notre
détermination sans faille pour que
l'alsace soit aussi au rendez-vous du
défi social et économique
plus que jamais unie et solidaire